Intrusion Detection Systems, or IDS for
short, are designed to counter
these types of threats.
They can be quite
effective against known or
less sophisticated attacks, such as
large scale email phishing attacks.
However, as attack techniques
become more sophisticated,
IDS will become less effective.
For example, attackers can blend attack
traffic with normal activities so
that it is very hard to
detect such attacks.
And the most sophisticated attackers,
in particular, the state-sponsored
attackers, may use new or
zero-day exploits to render
IDS completely ineffective.
Since IDS are not always effective,
they need to be part of
the defense-in-depth strategy for
an organization.
Typical defense-in-depth
strategies should include
encrypting sensitive information,
provide detail of the trails of
activities on systems and networks.
Use strong authentication and
access control.
Actively manage the security of
operating system and applications.